Monique Bonin est devenue maire de loin
en juin 2012 lorsque Rémy chintron a
quitté ce fauteuil pour présider le
conseil général lui-même succédant
Arnaud mbourg entré au gouvernement
aujourd'hui elle conduit la liste PS
pour les municipales est-ce un
leadership
provisoireon est actuellement président
du conseil général et c'est une fonction
qui lui va très bien je ne pense pas que
il serait intéressé par un retour en
tant que que maire de louange à mais de
toute façon nous avons un nous faisons
un travail
d'équipe donc si un jour on devait
revoir l'attribution des sièges ça ne
nous poserait pas de problème ni ni aux
uns ni aux autres pour l'heure en tout
cas Monique Bonin fait campagne et elle
a visiblement une cible privilégié c'est
une personne qui veut le pouvoir
elle a pas beaucoup de projet mais elle
veut elle veut être à la tête de la
ville Monique Bonin parle ainsi de
marie-fançoise Müller elle est à la tête
d'une liste dite citoyenne ce qui l'a
rempli d' le fait de faire ce ce projet
sans avoir de de compte à rendre à qui
que ce soit politiquement et bien je me
sens légère Marie Françoise Müller met
une sourdine à son engagement à gauche
elle fut notamment conseillère régionale
elle fut aussi maire délégué de
châorneau aujourd'hui cette commune
associée a disparu absorbé par loin
madame müer s'est battu contre la
décision préfectorale mais épise dit
n'explique pas sa candidature au revoir
ma démarche actuellement elle n'est pas
dans un esprit de revanche la page est
tournée pour moi et j'ai des projets
même pour le quartier de Château Renaud
puisque c'est un quartier maintenant
mais je trouve que c'est dommage d'avoir
donner un coup de canif dans notre
démocratie et dans le rapport à à nos
concitoyens le marché de loouan est
moins florissant qu'il n'a été et
dynamiser le développement économique et
touristique figure au programme de tous
les candidats Frédéric boucher agent
immobilier se présente comme un homme de
droite bien implanté dans sa ville moi
je sors du milieu associatif donc je
suis dans milieu associatif sportif
culturel économique voilà et à un moment
donné bon on a envie d'aller au-delà et
puis rendre à Lou en château Renaud tout
le bien qu'ils m'ont donné donc c'est
voilà c'est aussi une démarche
personnelle et une envie de faire donc
je me présente Sébastien Louin je suis
candidat à la liste donc Louan
châourneau bleu marine Sébastien loouin
dit bleu marine et pas Front national il
n'est pas le seul à parler de sécurité
mais on sent là un terrain de
prédilection nous avons commencé de
proposer
donc la l'installation de vidéo
protection pour assurer vraiment la
sécurité de tous nos concitoyens de nos
électeurs des habitants car on a une
recrudescence de de de la petite
délinquence de vol de braquage donc qui
devient quand même de plus en plus
important sur louand en dehors des
étiquettes des personnes et des
programmes la disparition de la commune
associée de chatorneau aura-t-elle un
impact sur l'élection loanaise c'est la
grande inconnue de ce
scrutin